I think porn has really changed the game  you know out of the gate now sex is much  kinkier I think is a porn out of the  gate now it's like choking spitting  finger up the butt which is weird cuz  these are all things my older brother  did to torment me it's all the same [ __ ]  we've just taken bullying out of the  playground brought in the bedroom I got  my girl on top now I'm like Indian  sunburn seriously you go to a schoolyard  during recess some kids holding roll  down pulling her hair calling her name's  I'm like man he's good I'm taking notes  get back to your girl she's like wow  where'd you learn that I'm like a couple  of third graders actually but don't  worry I like red wine  [Music]